un moment où le québec veut électrifier
ces transports regard ce soir sur
l'exploration minérale sur les plans
économiques environnementales et
sociales avec ugo lapointe qu'on
retrouve dans nos studios à ottawa hugo
lapointe bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
coordonnateur de miningwatch canada
cofondateur de la coalition pour que le
québec ait meilleure mine marre aussi de
plusieurs comités aviseurs consultatif
des gouvernements vous connaissez bien
sujet vous travailler là dessus depuis
des années c'est quoi votre
préoccupation première en terme de
développement minier minérale en ce
moment pour l'année 2020 au québec en
particulier
l'expansion des minéraux dits
stratégiques et critique
on parle notamment du lithium du
graphite des terres rares dans une
moindre mesure au québec avec
l'exploration l'augmentation de 50% du
graphite et 789 ou 6% du lithium ces
dernières années ça va être un enjeu
majeur parce que on voit plusieurs
projets venir débarquer dans des régions
qui sont pas nécessairement
traditionnement minière et qui suscite
beaucoup de préoccupations sociales
environnementales et il faut il faut
aussi comprendre que ce sont pour des
nouvelles technologies propres notamment
pour le transport vers l'électrification
des transports et aussi pour la
transition énergétique donc il ya quand
même des usages utiles ces minéraux des
usages utile nécessaire c'est comment le
faire finalement la grande question
exactement et là ça va se décliner
on pense qu'il va quand même y avoir un
peu d'accrochages ici c'est inévitable
est actuellement le gouvernement du
québec tente de
dans le fond il fait une consultation
publique sur les minéraux stratégiques
tente d'établir les bases d'un
développement de ces nouvelles filières
nous on encourage le gouvernement
actuellement le direct il faut réfléchir
de façon holistique à la question
environnementale mans parlant
socialement parlant économiquement aussi
avoir des investissements responsables
et viser les bons projets et éviter les
mots et les mauvais projets et ce sera
pas toujours évident il faut aussi
réduire à la source
voir qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
réduire la consommation ces minéraux là
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire aussi pour
le recyclage l'économie circulaire et
d'en faire penser dès maintenant au bout
à la fin de vie utile de ces minéraux là
pour pas les gaspiller
parce que sur le plan économique
aujourd'hui ou sur le plan financier en
termes de production
le québec a sous ses pieds un potentiel
qui est important pour répondre vous
pour répondre à une demande pour
répondre à la transition énergétique
oui et ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'actuellement il ya quand même des
jeux de géopolitique qui se dessine
l'europe soif de matières premières des
minéraux de ces minéraux stratégiques
notamment et critique les états unis
également hélas avec le don la
décarbonisation de l'économie donc on
s'éloigne du carbone du pétrole de
l'essence pour la remplacer avec
d'autres substances
les piles électriques des voitures
électriques notamment mais aussi les
piles pour le stockage d'énergie sont
son exige énormément de ressources
minérales et hélas le québec lui sur
cette plaque tournante internationale
est quand même assez bien situé et il
est grand et les riches y ait beaucoup
de ces matières la même plus qu'ailleurs
au canada
je dirais donc il ya quand même des
opportunités intéressantes mais ils vont
aussi avoir des défis environnementaux
et sociaux importants
est ce que le québec fait bien en cette
matière est ce que notre approche est
bonne sur le plan environnemental
c'est en cette matière nous ont dit on
peut faire mieux on s'est améliorée dans
les dernières années mais on peut faire
beaucoup mieux encore des gros enjeux et
un peu avant les fêtes à l'assemblée
nationale du québec nous et d'autres
organismes avons lancé dans une campagne
si on veut qu'on appelle les cinq
conditions pour que l'électrification
des transports ait meilleure mine la
transition énergétique ait meilleure
mine
et parmi ces cinq conditions là
essentiellement ce qu on dit faut
réduire à la source
d'abord donc on reparle de recyclage du
lithium d'une annonce qui a été faite
par le gouvernement du québec avant les
fêtes ça c'est une bonne nouvelle mais
il ya encore plus à faire des
évaluations environnementales pour
chaque musulman et encore des mines qui
sont pas évalués de façon vironnement
talent alors on peut pas prétendre faire
des transports vers des transports
propres si on ne fait pas d'évaluation
environnementale enfin ce qu'on dise il
faut surtout de donner aux municipalités
aux communautés locales des pouvoirs
décisionnels pour protéger les milieux
fragiles les milieux fragiles écologique
écologiquement fragiles mais également
socialement économiquement et là ça va
être tout un argent 2020 avec par
exemple grenville-sur-la-rouge le projet
de grafite le canada carbone qui
poursuit actuellement à des
municipalités pour 96 millions ou un
projet comme celui de nouveaux mondes
grafite à saint michel des saints dans
lanaudière
un milieu de villégiature
récréotouristique du parc du mont
tremblant et les consultations privées
nature absolument ça s'en vient le bas
puis voyant tout premier bape sur le
graphite au québec à la fin janvier
qu'il va débuter il va se prolonger
jusqu'à la fin du printemps
est-ce que vous avez rencontré justement
les ministres de l'énergie de
l'environnement avant les fêtes est ce
que vous êtes quand même rassuré par la
proche du gouvernement
le gros d'un secteur minier secteur
minéral à leur approche donc pour le
dire poliment je crois que le
gouvernement pourrait faire beaucoup
mieux on sent qu'une ouverture on sent
qu'une écoute textuellement gouvernement
consulte sur la question des minéraux
des minéraux stratégiques on va voir là
où ça va
ça va aboutir le plan de lutte aux
changements climatiques le plan
d'électrification de gouvernance québec
va être extrêmement important là dedans
on sent qu'il ya une hésitation encore
de la part du gouvernement de vraiment
travailler sur des mesures qui vont
réduire à la source et qui vont dans le
fond encourager des modes de transport
ça c'est surtout le transport des modes
de transport sobre en carbone mais sobre
également matériaux et récemment dans
l'actualité un enjeu majeur là dessus ça
va être de leur financement des
municipalités
une autre façon de financer municipalité
pour éviter l'étalement urbain qui est
très énergivore non seulement carbone
mais également en matériaux en minerais
en minéraux stratégiques éventuellement
pour des voitures électriques
donc première mine de graphite visant le
marché des véhicules électriques ça s'en
vient fin janvier nouveau monde
graphique pour le bape
et puis le lithium aussi un bac d'ici la
fin de 2020 qu'on va surveiller
hugo lapointe merci beaucoup pour cet
entretien ce soir et les priorités 2020
merci à vous merci à voir